Nehmen wir wieder den Flammen-Boy.
Ja, Pool-Level.
Ach, das ist das...
Da kann ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Das sind diese Nebel-Level, wo man dann später so ein Kleeblatt kriegt,
was das wegboostet.
Handy-Games, ja.
Das ist kein Handy-Game.
Läuft auf dem PC, ist halt
irgendeine Flash-Portierung.
Die anderen Teile gibt es soweit,
ich weiß gar nicht mehr auf dem PC.
Aber der erste Plants vs. Zombies-Teil,
finde ich, war auch am besten.
Da gab es halt noch kein Pay-to-Win.
Es war halt schon ein bisschen Handy-Game-Style,
dass du dann manchmal
das Game offen lassen sollst und sowas.
Aber ansonsten...
Das ist ein sehr schönes, entspanntes Game,
wo ich hauptsächlich Chat gucken kann
und nebenbei ein bisschen klicken und es passiert was.
Wie wäre es mit ein paar Metal-Covers?
Hast du welche?
Also ein paar Weihnachts-Metal-Covers.
Das ist ja immerhin der 25.
Kein Pay-to-Win? Nope.
Das erste Plants vs. Zombies hatte kein Pay-to-Win.
Das zweite verbinde ich im Kopf
irgendwie ein bisschen mit Pay-to-Win.
Ach, es ist ja Nacht-Level, WTF?
Nacht-Level, da brauche ich ja Pilze.
Also, ich hab...
Wo sind denn die Sonnen-Pilze?
Die hab ich jetzt gar nicht reingepackt.
Ei, ei, ei.
Build-Order-Fail.
Kiosk.
Ey, du bist ja auch wieder da.
Was, du warst gestern Abend auch da, ne?
Der Name kommt mir echt bekannt vor.
Das erste war noch gar nicht Funny-Ey, das ist richtig.
Das ist bevor PopCap.
Cap-Pop? Pop-Pop-Pop-Cap.
Funny-Ey gekauft wurde.
Boah, die Musik ist heute echt hardcore.
Aber da müssen wir durch, es ist Weihnachten.
Keine Chance.
Da können wir jetzt nicht dodgen oder so.
Da muss jetzt Weihnachtsmusik...
Muss jetzt.
Keine Chance.
Ist die Lautstärke von der Musik so in Ordnung?
Oder ist es zu laut?
Oh.
Der will gebasht werden.
Uh.
Oh, ich bin so voll, ey.
Ich kann mich überhaupt nicht mehr konzentrieren.
Ich muss eigentlich jetzt Tribble-Nators pflanzen.
Tribble-Nators.
Geschreckt.
Das haben wir.
So, jetzt können wir Tribble-Nators pflanzen.
Fertig.
Es ist nicht mehr.
Jetzt wieder.
Wird er gerackt.
Tyrannosaurus.
Schreckt wird er.
Der Zombie.
Klein Pilze kostet ja nichts, die kann man so oft bauen, wie man will.
Das Spiel ist doof, kann keiner 360 noscop montages machen.
Guck mal, mein Sonnenflick ist geil, oder?
Hast du den gesehen?
Der Sonnenflick.
Die Mausbeschleunigung in dem Game.
und in dem Game ist der Wahnsinn.
Hä?
Bam.
Look at that aim.
Moment, ist das deutsch?
Nein, das ist nicht deutsch.
Hat es doch angehört.
Ich verstehe bis heute nicht,
warum Maria Virgin sein musste.
Das macht es wahrscheinlich mysteriöser.
Ich denke mal,
der Josef hat wirklich schon die Arschkarte gehabt.
Da ging nichts.
Da wurde nicht weggeflankt damals.
Das war noch Zucht und Ordnung.
Oh, fertig schon.
Easy clap.
Das ist ein paar Träger.
Die Dinger verwende ich nie.
Die Laterndinge braucht man eigentlich nicht.
Man sieht genug, trotz Nebel.
So, das brauchen wir.
Sonnenpilz, diesmal machen wir es richtig.
Das da, das da.
Blätter.
Nuss.
Das da, das brauchen wir nicht.
Wir können ja nicht immer nur Tribblenatern.
Das wird ja auch langweilig.
Was nehmen wir noch?
Bam.
So.
Haha, Marvin.
Null.
Tja.
Immer noch Tilted von Overbought.
Nee, aber ich sehe es nicht, einen Rank zu spielen.
Zumindest nicht für die aktuelle Season.
Und ehrlich gesagt sehe ich es eigentlich auch überhaupt nicht, einen Rank zu spielen.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
Frank Sinatra Christmas Album.
Das war doch,
das hat ein bisschen
Schmackes gehabt, ja.
Ja, das ist doch ein bisschen,
da geht doch was.
Fahren wir mit Rainbow Six an.
Ich hab mit dem Eax zusammen vor ein paar Tagen
gespielt.
Wie gesagt, ich fand das Game schon gar nicht mal so kacke,
wie ich es zur Beta fand.
Ja, das mit BDO.
Oh, ich hab auch schon
Daily Quests und Zeug gemacht.
Also ich müsste jetzt endlich mal
auf 60 grinden, ja.
Wir spielen jetzt auch ein bisschen Blends vs. Zombies,
vor allem, bis ich ein bisschen verdaut habe und das alles
wieder ordentlich funktioniert.
Dann können wir, wenn ihr wollt, noch ein bisschen
BDO-Grind spielen.
Bisschen BDO
auf 60 grinden.
Bisschen sinnlos
im Kreis grinden und Mobs bashen.
Fragt mich nicht, warum ich den
jetzt ausgerechnet dahin gepflanzt hab, keine Ahnung.
Ey, lasst den in Ruhe.
Finger weg vom Pilz.
Dö-dö.
Snowen tut's bei uns garantiert nicht.
Boah, ich bin übrigens müde.
Dafuck.
Ach, der Blatt.
Ja, das sollt jetzt verrecken.
Oh, nice.
Mach ich zu.
Jaja, kannst du euch auch fressen.
Snow in 2K17, lull.
Moin, Ghost.
Freust du dich 2018
auf irgendwelche Spiele? Wir müssen uns gleich mal
eine Liste angucken, was 2018
eigentlich rauskommt.
Weil, selbst wenn ich
mich auf irgendein Spiel freue, ich vergesse immer,
wann die ganzen Sachen released werden.
Das können wir gleich mal machen. Wir gucken uns gleich mal
eine Release-Liste 2018 an.
Was da schönes kommt.
Letztes Video mit dem Friseur,
hätte ruhig länger sein können.
Ach, ich glaube, da wird sich,
hoffe ich mal,
in nächster Zeit vielleicht noch ein bisschen mal was ergeben.
Nicht unbedingt wieder 4 Jahre.
Oh, Moment, da schrecken meine Pilze.
Was ist denn mit dem los?
Das riecht ehrenlos,
der Zombie.
Ja, erlaubt ihn, ich bin auch
zaubermäßig müde.
Zu viel gefressen.
Den Super Nintendo.
Aus dem dann später die Playstation wurde,
weil Nintendo sich gedacht hat,
Sony deckt unseren Arsch.
Weiß, weiß ich, was da Nintendo
wieder geritten hat damals.
Genau, Secret of Mana war nämlich
ursprünglich für den
Super Nintendo CD-Laufwerk gedacht.
Das heißt, das Game hatte mit Sicherheit
sehr viel mehr Content geplant.
Vielleicht sogar Renderszenen,
was auch immer.
Keine Ahnung, was die genau geplant haben.
Wir werden es nie wissen.
So, und nachdem Nintendo ja das komplett
verschissen hat,
gab's das ja nie,
das CD-Laufwerk für den Super Nintendo.
Und es gab Secret of Mana
in der abgespeckten Version, was immer noch
ein saumäßig geiles Game war, mit einem der besten
Game-Soundtracks überhaupt. So, und jetzt
kommt das Remake raus.
Und das Remake sieht so scheiße aus.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Ich mein,
what the fuck?
ist das ein
ist das ein Free-to-Play-Mobile-Game
oder was?
Ich mein, wenn ich mir hier schon
das Model
hier von dem Mädel und der Kobold
den angucke, man, der Randy, der geht ja noch
irgendwie. Aber
da muss ich, da krieg ich echt
Kotzreflexe, ey, wenn ich das seh.
Oder sowas hier.
Guckt euch, also ganz
im Ernst.
Man muss kein Fan von Pixel-Grafik
sein.
Hätte auch nix dagegen, wenn das Spiel
in schöner
so Fake-2D-Grafik
gemacht wäre. Aber das hier, das ist
einfach, als hat man, für mich sieht das aus, als hat man
keinen Bock gehabt,
Ressourcen zu verschwenden mit Leuten,
die ordentliche Models machen, die ordentliche
Texturen, ich weiß nicht.
Das spricht mich überhaupt nicht an. Wenn man sich mal
paar Bilder anguckt von dem originalen
Super Nintendo Game, ja,
das sah für Super Nintendo Verhältnisse
auch nur ganz okay aus.
Das war halt ein Game, das kam so
in der Mitte der Lebenszeit.
Aber, das hat, das
war halt echt ne Grafik, die hatte
Charme, ja, wenn man sich das so anguckt.
Ich sag ja gar nicht, dass es genau
so aussehen müsste als Remake.
Aber irgendwas
so, was
so die gleichen Details
und, das sieht nicht aus
wie in Secret of Mana, das neue.
Äh, mach ich denn da?
Naja, also, wo wir da grad dabei sind,
also, nein, nein,
ich weiß gar nicht, ob,
vielleicht, ich werd mich wahrscheinlich trotzdem nicht
dazu hinreißen können.
Wobei, ich weiß, vielleicht, vielleicht kann ich mich doch nicht bremsen
und kauf's mir. Ich, ich weiß es nicht.
Okay, was kommt denn sonst noch?
März 2018, Far Cry 5.
Das, was ich gesehen hab, sah aus
wie Far Cry.
Seit Ubisoft halt
die Far Cry Dinger bastelt.
Also, besser gesagt,
seitdem es nicht mal Crytek macht.
Also, quasi, sie sind nach Far Cry 1.
Ähm, und,
pfff,
also, mich hat das Setting nicht geschockt
von Far Cry 5.
Und, noch mal
das gleiche,
was ja im Endeffekt 3 und 4 schon,
ja, oder weniger das gleiche Game waren, bloß unterschiedliche
Setting, brauch ich net.
Pizza Connection 3
konnt vielleicht ganz lustig werden,
aber, jo, mich auch net.
Sea of Thieves.
Ich predikte einfach mal,
das wird ein Spiel, was
mit vielen Ambitionen wird aber
failen. Das ist dieses, dieses
Piraten-Multiplayer-Spiel auf der Xbox.
Xbox 0.
Und zweitens hat man
viele coole Szenen gesehen
auf den Pressekonferenzen und auch
in den Trailern und sowas. Die große
Preisfrage bei sowas ist immer, wenn die immer
nur coole Szenen zeigen, ist
wie fügen die sich zusammen?
Du kannst aus jedem Mist
coole Szenen rausschneiden, ja.
Die trashigsten Filme haben ganz coole Trailer
teilweise, oder zumindest ein cooles Cover.
Ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen, dass es was wird, aber da bin ich gespannt.
Da bin ich nicht irgendwie gehypt drauf, da bin ich echt gespannt.
A Way Out sagt mir gar nix.
Von wem ist das?
Von EA.
Und wer macht's?
Okay, das ist ganz, das war ganz nett.
Gefängnis-Ausbruch-Simulator.
Das, das klingt
ganz interessant. Hab ich mich aber noch nicht mit beschäftigt.
Das hab ich überhaupt
nicht mitgekriegt, dass das überhaupt schon
demnächst kommt.
Der erste Teil war wirklich super.
Also, ich muss euch, ich hab,
es gibt, ich muss
jetzt mal in mich gehen, bevor ich sag, es gibt
kein hübscheres Spiel auf der PS3
als das erste Ni No Kuni.
Aber zumindest vom
Style her und sowas ist das erste
Ni No Kuni wirklich,
sagen wir's mal, eines der hübschesten
Spiele, die es auf der Playstation 3
gegeben hat. Das war wirklich ein tolles
Game. The Far Cry 5
juckt mich nicht.
Agony sagt mir nix.
Was ist das?
Ist das Gollum oder was soll das?
Ist das ein Herr-der-Ringe-Spiel?
Kickstarter. Na, da warten wir mal ab.
Wizard of Legends.
Das ist ja schon ein Titel, da klingt's ja trashig.
Was ist das?
Das ist bestimmt ein Mobile-Game.
Sagt mir alles nix.
Warum ist denn die Game Start so langsam?
Please!
Was auch immer, sagt mir nix.
Attack on Titan 2 juckt mich auch nicht.
Of Gods Redemption sagt mir auch nix.
Ghost of a Tale.
Da hab ich mir mal ein paar Sachen auf Steam angeguckt.
Das sah ganz interessant aus.
Das ist mit der Maus.
Dieser Maus als Held.
Schleich-Game.
Da bin ich mal gespannt drauf.
Hellpoint sagt mir gar nix.
Moons of Madness sagt mir auch nix.
Undungeon sagt mir auch nix.
Ohne Werbung.
Ja, wisst ihr was?
Live Adblock Installation.
Ich muss erst mal gucken,
ob ich das Richtige installiere.
Ja, das ist das Richtige.
So.
Ist es jetzt schneller?
Die Seite sieht auch viel besser aus gleich.
We Happy Few.
Das verbinde ich irgendwie mit Xbox
exklusiv und
ein bisschen abgedreht und hab mich auch
schon beim Trailer nicht gejuckt.
Genau.
Weiß nicht, was das ist.
Juckt mich nicht.
Conan Exile.
Wird das mal wieder gebolten ein bisschen?
Ach, das war dieses Survival-Ding.
Nee, das ist...
Das ist ein Negativ-Hype.
Neues Metro. Das könnte mich interessieren.
Die ersten paar Metro-Games. Zwei gab's, ne?
Zwei. Die ersten... Drei?
Last Light gab's noch, ne?
Drei. Ich glaub drei Metro-Games gab's mittlerweile.
Ähm...
Die waren ganz gut.
Pathfinder. Das klingt nach nem RPG.
Könnte was sein.
Und das war's.
Mehr nicht. Mehr ist noch nicht bekannt,
was 2018 kommt. Laut Wikipedia
kommt da... kommt da... äh...
Naja.
Also bis jetzt war da nix dabei,
worauf ich mich wahnsinnig freuen würde 2018.
Wo ich ja mal gespannt
drauf bin.
Ah, hier oben ist nochmal...
Oh, es gibt ein neues Ace Combat.
Das ist so Arcade-
Flug-Shooter-Dings-Zeug.
Da haben mir die Teile früher übelst viel Spaß gemacht.
Mal gucken, wie das neu wird.
Ähm, was wollte ich jetzt grad sagen?
Ja, wo ich mal wirklich
gespannt drauf bin.
Was Camelot Unchained macht
nächstes Jahr.
Die erzählen ja schon seit eineinhalb Jahren, dass
die Beta demnächst mal startet.
Aber sieht nicht so aus. Da bin ich mal gespannt,
was rauskommt.
Eines der wenigen Sachen, die ich gebackt habe damals
auf Kickstarter, mit ich glaube
und es lacht mich nicht aus,
ja, ich glaube mit 300 Euro.
Für den Game,
was wahrscheinlich nie fertig wird.
Pech gehabt.
RIP.
RIP Money.
Lol, ja ne.
Hey, man muss dazu sagen,
ich bin, also Dark Edge of Camelot
ist das Game, wo ich mit Abstand,
wirklich mit riesen, mit Meilenweit,
Kilometer Abstand
die meiste Spielzeit drinne hab.
Und das ist von dem
Typ, der ursprünglich auch Dark Edge of Camelot
entwickelt hat.
Oder Chef entwickelt hat.
Marc Jacobs.
Und
dachte mir so, hey, wenn mal
wieder irgendwas in dieser Richtung rauskommt,
dann muss man das supporten.
Das waren natürlich auch rosa-rote Brille, ja.
In 2018 könnten einige
gute Konsolen-Exklusivtitel kommen.
Hast du da ne Liste, wo wir mal
gucken können, dann können wir uns die noch zusammen angucken.
Also
post einfach mal nen Link, wenn du
ne gute Liste und gute Übersicht hast über
Konsolenspiele 2018.
Hast du dir
mittlerweile Pupke mal wieder angesehen?
Nein. Ich wette mit euch, die
Performance ist noch genauso schlecht.
Moin Xkillards.
Das ist richtig
klassischer Call of Duty
Quickscope Name, Xkillards.
Also damit hättest du früher
Montages machen können.
Xkillards HD
Production Presents.
Und dann MW2 Rust
180 Kreisel vom
Turm runter mit der Intervention.
Oder wirklich
mit der
Brille.
Und das ist
genau so, wie es
eigentlich
aussehen würde.
Stimmt.
Jetzt springt
ein bisschen
die
Blitz,
und dann
fängt
Irgendwie ist es sehr...
Wir werden jetzt einmal platt gefahren.
Damn.
Ja, endlich.
Kann man das denn ein bisschen wegpusten?
Warum habe ich 155 Zuschauer?
Alter, warum?
Okay, ich habe ein paar Sachen übersehen im Chat.
Wir gucken uns jetzt erstmal Xbox und PS4 Games an.
Aber vorher lese ich mal Chat.
Äh, Ashen, dann kann ich dir leider nichts zu sagen.
Wir haben gestern ein bisschen zusammen geguckt.
Aber für 5 Euro fällt mir nichts ein.
Hey, ich habe eine Frage.
Mein selbstgebauter Rechner geht sofort wieder aus, wenn ich ihn einschalte.
Woran liegt das?
Hast du alle Stromkabel angeschlossen?
Mal ganz doof gefragt.
Also sprich, das fette ATX-Kabel und diese kleinen 4-Pin-Dinger.
Sind dir irgendwelche Schrauben reingefallen oder so?
Ich tippe mal drauf, du hast nicht alle Stromkabel angeschlossen.
Dann kann das nämlich auch sein.
Dann drückst du Power on, geht der Lüfter kurz an und gleich wieder aus.
Also musst du mal gucken, du musst das ATX-Kabel reinstecken.
Je nachdem, wenn daneben noch Platz ist, dann musst du da noch einen 4-Pin reinstecken.
Aber aktuelle Netzteile haben quasi schon den ATX-Stecker, der breit genug ist.
Ich glaube 24 Pin.
Und dann brauchst du noch 1 bis 2 weitere 4-Pin-Stecker, die du aufs Mainboard machen musst.
Wenn du die nicht drauf machst, dann geht es nicht an, wenn du Pech hast.
Ja, ja, ich weiß, was FFZ ist.
Einfach nur...
Aber das Schöne an Better Twitch TV ist, Better Twitch TV Emotes funktionieren mit Better Twitch TV und FFZ.
Umgedreht nicht.
Gibt es die Charaktere nur im Shop vom Dave?
Nein, die kriegt man hier nach Level beenden.
Okay, auch nochmal lange Frage.
Wenn wir gerade bei PC sind.
Mein PC bleibt ca. einmal wöchentlich beim Spielen einfach hängen.
Tut sich nix mehr.
Als ich noch die Soundkarte drin hatte, hat sich der Sound dann geloopt.
Ohne Soundkarte bleibt er einfach nur hängen.
Woran könnte das liegen?
Das kann ja an fast allem liegen.
Von RAM kaputt bis zu heiß.
Das kann ja fast alles sein.
Wobei ich mal drauf tippen würde, irgendwelche komischen Hersteller-Treiber oder so, die merkwürdige Dinger machen.
Wenn wirklich RAM kaputt wäre, dann hättest du wahrscheinlich öfters Probleme.
Und überhitzen wird wahrscheinlich auch nix.
Davon kackt er in der Regel auch nicht ab.
Was du machen kannst, du kannst mal einen RAM-Test machen, ob es da nicht wirklich Probleme gibt.
Ansonsten kann das alles sein, wenn der Rechner einmal in der Woche hängen bleibt.
Im Zweifelsfall sogar irgendeinen Windows-Bug.
Wie bist du eigentlich auf die Idee gekommen, wieder Plants vs. Zombies zu zocken?
Ja.
Weil ich gestern, nachdem ich mich vollgefressen habe, gedacht habe, ich könnte nochmal eine Runde streamen.
Da habe ich irgendein Game gebraucht, was man halb Gehirn-AFK spielen kann.
So, und jetzt gucken wir uns mal Games an für PS4 und Xbox.
Kann man eigentlich nur die CPU austauschen, ohne weitere Änderungen?
Ja, kannst du machen.
Warum auch nicht?
Musst gucken, dass die CPU von deinem Mainboard unterstützt wird.
Dann kannst du einfach die CPU austauschen.
Das ist kein Ding.
Überprüft Windows nicht bei jedem Start den RAM.
Keine Ahnung, ob das Windows macht, aber es kann kein großartig ausführlicher Test sein, weil es geht viel zu schnell.
So, dann gucken wir uns jetzt mal Games an für die PS4.
Was da so rauskommt.
Display Capture.
Bam.
Also, PS4-Spiele 2018.
Was haben wir denn da so Schönes?
Ni no Kuni 2, das haben wir gerade schon gesehen.
Da bin ich mal gespannt drauf.
Das war definitiv eines der hübschesten Spiele auf der PS3.
Okay, ein Remake, was die Welt nicht braucht.
Also, versteht mich nicht falsch, das war ein super Game.
Aber das gab es schon mal, ein Remake auf die PS3.
Und nochmal.
Wobei, man schauen muss, wie sie es machen.
Also, wenn es nicht einfach nur aufpoliert ist, das alte...
Gucken wir mal in den Trailer rein.
Wenn einfach nicht nur das alte aufpoliert ist, sondern wirklich auch neu gemacht wurde.
Also sprich, nicht einfach nur höhere Texturen rein, sondern so wie das bei der Wand hier, ehrlich gesagt, schon aussieht.
Das wird es schon rechtfertigen.
Ja, das sieht schon aus, wie nicht rein aufgebohrt.
Man sieht jetzt auch nicht aus, wie unbedingt ein Game, wenn man sich hier mal den Boden und so anguckt.
Sieht auch nicht aus, wie unbedingt ein Game von 2018.
Die Haare sahen übrigens damals schon geil aus, auf der PS2.
Es sieht mehr aus, wie so ein Zwischending.
Zwischen quasi, das alte ein bisschen aufpoliert und ein paar neue qualitativ höherwertigere Sachen eingefügt.
Also, ein Remake.
Aber eigentlich brauchen wir es nicht, nochmal.
Ghost of... Ghost of was?
Tsushima.
Weil der Japaner sagt dann wahrscheinlich Tsushima.
Oder irgendwie so.
Raus.
Ein Famous Entwickler.
Aha.
Einen Samurai.
Was ausgefallen ist.
Auf die Idee gekommen,
ein japanisches Spiel zu machen,
wo man einen Samurai spielt.
Das gab es ja noch nie.
Indem die Mongolen-Invasion in Japan startet.
Die Armee zerfällt zuerst auf...
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Sagt mir gar nichts.
Juckt mich nicht.
Mal gespannt.
Vor allem bin ich mal gespannt,
wie sie das jetzt hintreten,
dass Kratos doch noch lebt.
Weil ich mein, Spoiler,
Kratos ist gestorben am Ende des letzten Teils.
Oder ist das gar nicht Kratos?
Ist das nur einer,
der zufällig so aussieht?
Oder spielt man jetzt Kratos Sohn?
Hat Kratos überhaupt Kinder?
Oder ist das nur einer,
der zufällig so aussieht?
Nee, der Typ sieht gar nicht so aus.
Wobei, ja, doch schon.
Ist das Kratos oder ist das nicht Kratos?
Weil es könnte ja auch ein nordischer Kratos sein.
Okay, es ist doch Kratos.
Steht ja auch da.
Mal gucken,
ob man jetzt wirklich,
ob die Welt wirklich noch ein neues God of War braucht.
Verkaufszahlen werden bestimmt gut sein
und Fights mit Sicherheit wieder grandios inszeniert.
Spoiler, man juckt mich nicht.
Ähm, da bin ich gespannt drauf.
Soweit ich mich erinnern kann,
ist das doch das Spiel
zur damaligen Tech-Demo
mit diesem,
mit diesem Roboter,
der abgeschaltet werden sollte.
Wie hieß das denn?
Kara, genau.
Ist das nicht,
ist das nicht das Spiel,
was aus Kara damals entstanden ist?
Da muss ich jetzt mal nachgucken.
Ja, genau.
Ja, da bin ich gespannt drauf.
Guck mal, wie der Alan Page mit dabei ist,
die dann wieder Sony verklagen kann,
weil ein Nacktmodel von ihr im Game war.
So ein Scheiß.
So, blöd.
Plötzchen merkt man sich, ja.
Okay, was gibt's als nächstes?
Was gibt's noch für Sachen?
Die, oh, Digimon-Story, ja, unbedingt.
Dragon Ball Fighter, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Also, die Grafik sieht einfach räudig aus.
Haben wir uns schon angeguckt.
Secret of Mana Remake haben wir uns auch schon angeguckt.
The Crew 2 juckt mich nicht.
Far Cry 5 hatten wir grad schon mal.
Ist mir auch egal.
Das ist so ein Mittelalter-Fighting-Game.
Ist nicht.
Juckt mich nicht.
Könnte mich interessieren.
Die Mega Man X Collection.
Ist das, das ist die alten Mega Man Games,
bloß jetzt zusammen, oder?
Red Dead Redemption 2, da bin ich mal gespannt drauf.
Final Fantasy Remake ist was, was ich persönlich nicht brauch.
Darksiders 3 hab ich keine großartigen Hoffnungen drin.
S.7.
Jo, wenn das so gut wäre wie die alten Teile.
Dann ist das was, was mir Spaß machen könnte.
Last of Us 2 bin ich gespannt drauf.
Death Stranding bin ich auch gespannt drauf.
Da habt ihr wahrscheinlich auch alle den Trailer geguckt und euch am Ende gefragt,
okay, ich hab jetzt 10 Minuten Trailer geguckt und weiß immer noch nicht, was das sein soll.
Fortnite, putz.
Naja, so, und jetzt, jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt, was gibt's jetzt für die Xbox.
Das hält sich wahrscheinlich in Grenzen, was es da Exklusives gibt.
Crackdown 3 juckt mich nicht.
Sea of Thieves juckt mich auch nicht, hatten wir grad schon.
Juckt mich auch nicht.
Ich weiß nicht.
Der erste Teil war nett.
Gucken, wie das wird.
Das sieht für mich aus wie, wir machen das pixellig, weil die Leute denken, Pixel-Grafik ist retro und cool.
Monster Hunter World.
Da muss ich sagen, eine Serie, die bisher voll an mir vorbeiging.
Ich hab Monster Hunter auf der Wii gespielt, aber ich hab nie den Reiz davon verstanden.
Nachdem das jetzt ja auch quasi genauso Leute ansprechen soll wie mich, die noch nie was Großartiges...
Monster Hunter am Hut hatten, bin ich mal echt gespannt drauf.
EA, Resident Sleeper.
Ja, und im Prinzip, der Rest ist einfach Cross-Plattform hier.
Metal Gear Survive, das wird grausam schlecht.
Näh.
Also, bis auf 3, 4, ne Handvoll Games.
Darksiders 3 wird nix.
Ich sag's euch, Leute.
Das Beste an Darksiders war eindeutig die Optik.
Und sie haben den originalen Artist nicht mehr dabei.
Also den originalen Konzept-Art- und Designer-Typ.
Ich weiß nicht, wie der hieß.
Von Darksiders 1 und 2 ist er nicht mehr dabei.
Ups.
So.
In dem Chat irgendwas überlesen?
Außer Diskussion, was für Boards und CPUs und sonst was?
Weiter geht's.
So.
Den da, den da.
Den da.
Fliegezombies.
Den da, den da, den da.
Und.
Den da, den da.
Ist eigentlich wurscht, kriegen wir so auch easy hin.
Ach ne, Moment, ich brauch Blätter.
Dann nicht den da, dann den da.
Dann Spam, dann Kaktus.
Kaktus-Spam is real.
Darksiders ist mega geil.
Ich glaube nicht, dass der dritte Teil gut wird.
Der erste Teil ist echt geil.
Der erste Teil war gut, der zweite Teil war gut.
Wobei der zweite Teil ganz schöne Längen hatte.
Und die Story vom ersten Teil nicht erreicht hat.
Den ersten Teil fand ich rundum gut von Darksiders.
Ich glaube nicht, dass Darksiders 3 was wird.
Allein schon, also die Hambamere schon sind ein bisschen unten durch.
Ich hab halt das erste Konzeptart gesehen und das erste Bild, was sie quasi veröffentlicht haben von dem Rider, den man jetzt spielt.
Und ich hab halt das erste Konzeptart gesehen und das erste Bild, was sie quasi veröffentlicht haben von dem Rider, den man jetzt spielt.
Darksiders 3 und dann ist es dir direkt ins Auge gesprungen, dass das nicht mehr von dem Originaltyp erstellt wurde.
Und für mich war der Look von Darksiders eines der besten Sachen.
Aber Darksiders 3 ist doch Darksiders 1 plus 2.
Quick Muffs!
Wann hab ich schlaue Zuschauer?
1 plus 2 ist 3.
Big Shark.
Das ist ja das Leben des Jahres, der Typ.
Die meisten Mainstream-Memes finde ich ja doof, weil halt Mainstream muss man ja aus Prinzip doof finden.
Aber Big Shark, das finde ich geil.
Oh, ich muss Kaktus pflanzen.
Wenn ich kein Kaktus pflanze, dann habe ich ja das gleiche Problem wie eben.
Also, Kaktus.
Command-Prew.
Kaktus.
Hammer-Ober an.
Und Kaktusen weiter.
Kickstart hat.
Gibt es in Plants vs. Zombies eigentlich auch 1 vs. 1, weil er Zombies spielt?
Also, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, hat das Game kein Multiplayer.
Müssen wir mal im Hauptmenü gucken.
Mal kurz gucken, ob der jetzt eine andere Playlist...
Der hat eine andere Playlist angemacht.
ETF.
Warum?
Warum macht der einfach jetzt was anderes an?
Ich habe gestern Autoplay ausgeschaltet.
So, das haben wir überall.
Gekaktust.
Easy Win.
Ich glaube, du hast den Schlingtank vergessen.
Ja, den hätte ich mitnehmen können.
Aber den brauchen wir nicht.
Alter, in der Weihnachtszeit gibt es ein Stream-Gewitter.
Ich habe Urlaub.
Das liegt gar nicht so sehr an Weihnachten, sondern weil ich jetzt den ganzen Dezember Urlaub hatte und habe.
Pst, schreckt.
Machen wir hier ein bisschen Buffer vorne hin noch.
Puste.
Oh, so viel Rot im Chat.
Das habe ich jetzt übersehen.
Hast du das gekauft oder hast du es dir geholt, als es free war?
Ich habe es mir auf der Xbox damals gekauft und in Origin habe ich gestern gesehen, es
ist einfach Trille gewesen.
Also ich gehe mal davon aus, ich habe mir das geholt, als es free gewesen ist.
Easy Win.
Easy Life.
Easy Kaktus.
Ich habe das gesehen, es war Huge Kaktus ist das gerade.
Massive.
Wir sitzen alle am PC während unserer Familie.
Mit Elefanten im Wohnzimmer, na klar, ist auch besser so, Familienstelz kann man auch
übertreiben.
Die Delfin Sounds.
Oh, Easy Win.
Jetzt kann ich Chat gucken, jetzt muss ich hier nichts mehr machen.
Ah, hier, guck mal, das Sbarro ist am Start.
Previously, so, das war das.
Das war das.
Sie sagt, ich will wieder Berufsschule, habe besondere Gründe dafür?
Lass mich raten.
Wenn man unbedingt Berufsschule haben will, so.
Da gibt es ja eigentlich, äh also, zwei Gründe fallen mir da spontan ein.
Entweder geht einem die Arbeit auf den Sack, w mister man lieber Berufsschule hat oder
man hat vielleicht irgendwelche Grills in der Klasse.
Ja.
Was auch immer es davon jetzt ist.
Eins von beiden wird es wahrscheinlich sein, oder?
Blub, blub, blub.
Oh, wir können uns Sonnenblumen-Upgrades kaufen.
Nice.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Im Prinzip können wir uns eh nur...
Ach, kann man noch nicht klicken.
Sonnenblumen-Upgrades.
Wobei, eigentlich habe ich immer so viele Sonnen am Ende der Runde.
Ich glaube, ich brauche für den normalen Story-Modus überhaupt keine Sonnenblumen-Upgrades.
Minigames, yeah.
Oh, ich dachte, er springt jetzt nach da.
Nee, macht er nicht.
Hochkomplexer Modus.
Ganz furchtbar schwierig.
Was ist das hier?
Warum springst du nicht nach da?
Kackding.
Ja, muss dann halt der Rasenmäher ohren.
Wir hatten im ersten Lehrjahr eine Referendarin, die jetzt Englischlehrerin ist, auf die ich stehe.
Und ich bin im Englischkurs.
Ich wusste es doch, dass es irgendwie sowas in der Richtung ist.
Ist doch klar.
Es gibt ja eigentlich schon zwei Möglichkeiten, wenn man gerne in die Berufsschule geht.
Ha ha.
Oh, blub, blub, blub, blub, blub.
Sind da vielleicht nochmal Zombies drin?
Easy.
Gigi-Eats.
Hehe.
Ja, Wiesbrot, das stimmt.
Er schreibt, es ist schon schlimm, wenn man instant von Echtgeld ausgeht, sobald man ein Eurozeichen in den Ingame-Shops sieht.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber, das war noch vor EA-Zeiten von PopCap.
Ha.
Da gab es noch keine Pay-to-Win-Geschichten in dem Game.
Was sind das denn für Sonnenblumen?
Das haben die 5k kosten.
Das sind Sonnenblumen-Upgrades.
Da gibt eine Sonnenblume quasi auf einem Feld doppelt so viel Sonne.
Kostet aber halt 150 Sonnen.
Das lohnt sich in den meisten Kampagnen-Leveln nicht.
Die sind zu kurz.
In diesem Endlos-Modus oder halt in diesem Challenge-Modus lohnt sich das dann auf jeden Fall.
Sehr schweres Minigame.
Massive schwer.
So, easy geschafft.
Das ist eine Pflanze, die braucht man nie.
GG Eats.
Next.
Anstatt Solar-Panels auf dem Dach einfach Sonnenblumen pflanzen.
Ja, so einfach kann es sein.
Ich finde es eigentlich egal, ob man Sonnenblumen oder Pilze nimmt.
Ja, wir haben keine Fliegezorn.
Wir haben diese...
Ach, deswegen hat man...
Das hier gekriegt, weil hier diese Maulwurf-Buddel-Zombie-Dinger am Start sind.
Aber die sind so einfach.
Die können auch ein paar Sonnenblumen wegfressen oder ein paar Pilze.
Das ist egal.
Warum haben wir wieder Triple Nators?
Triple Nators.
Ich habe das vergessen.
Das brauchen wir noch.
Und jetzt nehmen wir als letztes noch...
Bam.
Boom.
Nehmen wir mit.
Big Shrug.
Boom.
Beatbrot schreibt.
Haben heute mal wieder Battlefield 4 in Szene.
Seit langem Battlefield 3 spielen.
Gefühlt ist der Battlefield 3-Netcode mittlerweile ja viel schlechter als der von Battlefield 4.
Ja, das stimmt.
Deswegen verstehe ich es nicht, warum sie bei Battlefield 1 am Anfang so Probleme hatten.
Dass du durchgeschossen hast durch die Gegner.
Weiß nicht, wie es jetzt ist in Battlefield 1.
Ja, previously.
Ich glaube, das ist recht unwahrscheinlich.
Gibt es Statistiken von Twitch über die Grillquote?
Gute Frage.
Ich habe mir die Analyse-Seiten von Twitch noch nie angeschaut.
Könnte mir aber vorstellen, dass es sowas gibt.
Weil wenn jemand...
diesem Sauerer seinen Stream...
optimieren will, was auch immer man da jetzt genau darunter versteht.
Ist nicht schlecht zu wissen, wer zuguckt, in welchem Alter, welches Geschlecht.
Nicht verkehrt.
Deswegen gehe ich davon aus, dass es wahrscheinlich sowas gibt in den Twitch-Statistiken.
Ich habe aber wie gesagt noch nie geguckt.
Gritz.
Den Bot-Befehl habe ich genau deswegen eingeführt.
Warte.
Hör auf.
Zombie, geh weg.
Piss dich, Alde.
So, jetzt wollen wir mal hier ein bisschen Sonnen-Sammel und Tribble-Nators pflanzen.
Tribble-Nators.
Bam, Tribble-Nator.
Wow.
Der Rätsel-Modus.
So, so.
Oh, da ist er hier.
Da stellt's da.
Ich kann gar nichts machen.
Bam.
Oh, Sonnen-Sammel für Tribble-Nators.
Huge Tribble-Nators.
Micro-SD-Karten bekommst du auf Amazon hinterhergeworfen.
Ja, generell ist so Flash-Geschichten, wenn es jetzt nicht gerade Terabyte-weise ist, ziemlich günstig geworden in den letzten Jahren.
Zum Glück.
Das ist eines der besten Erfindungen aller Zeiten.
SSDs, also Flash-Speicher in ordentlicher Größe.
Beste.
Schau mal, da sind Dinger.
Easy-Level.
Yeets.
Easy, da müssen wir halt gar nichts machen.
Wann bin ich eigentlich schon on?
Ich werd echt müde gerade.
Erste Stunde.
Ich glaube, das mit BDO-Kreise-Leveln lassen wir heute.
Ähm, bin ich im Arsch.
Ich hab nicht so viel gefressen.
Keine Fliege-Zombies.
Komm, wir pilzen einfach mal ordentlich auf hier.
Ordentlich aufgepilzt.
Die Dinger habe ich nie verwendet, diese Sternenfrucht-Teile.
Keine Ahnung, ob die was trauen.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es auch so easy win.
Das nehmen wir noch mit.
Ja, so.
Okay, da ist jetzt sogar noch mehr Nebel, da brauchen wir das auf jeden Fall, das Teilnetz.
Morgen ist auch noch ein Teil, ja, das stimmt, Sibaro.
Parada.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es ja schon so, Andron mach ich auch gleich schluss.
Ah, ich bin echt gerade kaputt, jetzt setzt du voll das Koma ein.
Außerdem ist ja morgen immer noch Weihnachten.
Jetzt wo wir uns hier gerade erleben haben für PC, Xbox und PS4.
Wo jetzt für mich ja nicht so viele Hype-Sachen dabei waren.
Also gäbe es denn für euch irgendwas worauf ihr euch wirklich freut?
nächstes Jahr.
Ist das die Vape Nation Map?
Weißt du nicht, was die Zombies hier
offscreen machen?
Monster hat er für den PC, okay.
Ja, da bin ich auch
gespannt drauf.
Wie gesagt, zumal das ja diesmal
so gemacht sein soll, dass es eben auch genau Leute
wie mich anspricht, die nichts bisher
mit der Reihe groß am Hut hatten.
Battlefront
3 Fanmade.
Ähm, auf Basis
von was?
Das klingt interessant.
Also das klingt spannend.
Auf welcher Basis
wird das gemacht?
Also was ist da grundlagetechnisch?
Ja, Darksiders, aber du hast es gerade kaputt gehört.
Naja, wie gesagt, ich habe halt
nicht so die großen Hoffnungen. Darksiders 3.
Half-Life 3.
Ganz bestimmt, ja.
ist das Jahr für Half-Life.
Half-Life 3, ja, ich hab's im Urin.
Ich, ich, ich,
ich fühl's schon quasi.
Half-Life 3.
Das muss ich dann auch let's playen über die nächsten
zwei Jahre.
Das neue Elder Scrolls.
Kommt doch kein neues Elder Scrolls.
Gibt bestimmt wieder das
85. Skyrim Remake.
Also soweit ich weiß,
kommt 2018 kein neues Elder Scrolls.
Die haben doch sogar erst
die haben doch sogar erst erzählt,
irgendwie groß verkündet, sie wollen in nächster Zeit kein neues Elder Scrolls machen.
Der Source wurde mal geleakt, Mensch Mann, okay.
Aha.
Vielleicht gibt's ja dann auch noch ein gutes neues Battlefront.
Paarhautgröße, 52 GB.
Ich seh's schon, komm, äh,
wenn ich, wenn ich, wenn ich sehe, wie fett Games mittlerweile sind
und ich mich manchmal,
ich frag mich manchmal, warum?
Also ich mein, ja, selbst
große Texturen und
aber um auf 50
GB zu kommen,
da musst du dich schon echt anstrengen.
Oder, oder komplett unkomprimiertes
Audio noch reinhauen und sowas.
Keine Ahnung, was
mir da, was da abgeht.
Plants vs. Zombies ist 250 MB.
Und das ist ein komischer
Flashport, der könnte wahrscheinlich noch viel kleiner sein.
Quantum Break 70.
70 GB,
allen Ernst, ich hab mir das ja bei Steam vor zwei Tagen
äh, nee, gestern, gestern gekauft.
70.
70 GB.
Na gut, dass ich den 2 TB
SSD hab.
Endlich hat das mal den Sinn.
Hast du auch mal Plants vs. Zombies
äh, ähm, Garden Warfare
gezockt? Ja.
Fand ich gut.